here at the White House we were invited
by the first family for the annual
Easter Egg Roll their final and I
decided you know what I'm gonna bring
two very special reporters with me my
son Shane and his friend Gabriel this is
your final Easter Egg Roll was it like
getting ready it's a little bittersweet
you know I mean this is one of our
favorite events today there'll be 35,000
so a lot of it they're kids
who would never gain access to spend an
afternoon or a couple of hours on the
South Lawn of the White House will you
miss most when you leave the White House
it's really the people I talked to the
girls about the fact that there'll be
people that they may not see again it's
being able to give the American people
access to the special place kids like
you guys you get to come in and do
interviews today's festivities included
hoops with Shaquille O'Neal some tennis
some storytime they roared their
terrible roars let's hear it roar
Beyonce was here in a white and pink
Easter outfit that Blue Ivy with the
bunny ears Jay Z also here and there was
also a fun run in the Obama's backyard
whatever plans Rock to leave the White
House good question
well I want to make sure that my girls
are settled no matter how important your
parents are they're always worried about
you guys first have you noticed that
about your parents well I'm the same way
I'm not take a break - all right I might
go to a spa if you guys know what a
spy's yeah I might do that couple of
days but don't tell the president but
he's not invited you mentioned the girls
they recently attended the state dinner
and it seemed like they had so much fun
what was it like for you watching them
well the back story to that is that as I
started thinking about their experience
I realized because we generally just
don't include the girls we've tried to
normalize
their lives as much as possible but I
realized that they hadn't been to a
state dinner now all these years they
had never been to a state dinner so I
thought you know when they look back on
this time when they are talking to their
kids and they're like mom did you ever
go to a state dinner and they say no I
would feel pretty bad about that and now
we're little ladies yeah
people went crazy and you know pictures
especially the Ryan Reynolds one with
the two sister loved it really is a
special day being here and talking to
the first lady and by the way during
their tenure the Obamas have hosted more
than 250,000 people for the annual
Easter Egg Roll